if your neighbors suddenly started dying
and turning into plants what would you
do you're trapped on This Island full of
murderers and god-like creatures and
it's only a matter of time before your
turn to die comes I'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to beat the fish gods in
housing complex C these people have no
idea that everyone on this island is
going to die and it's not going to be
due to old age Kimmy here is just your
regular old little girl living in a
small town and more specifically within
a housing complex full of senior
citizens she complains that it's hot as
hell and asks if they can have some
shaped ice to cool off so they take her
down to the town's old basement and
begin looking for their old ice machine
but find something else instead and
Kimmy suddenly finds the rotten corpse
of an old dog and also discovers a rock
with a creepy mark on it not realizing
that this rock will unleash something
horrifying old man taka here then
realizes that this storeroom was built
on an unexplored ancient cave and now
thinks that this prehistoric Rock could
be worth a lot of money he goes to tell
his friends that he thinks that this
rock belongs to an ancient civilization
that used to live on this island and
tells everyone that they should start
exploring this island in case there is
even more treasure to be found but he'll
soon regret digging any further suddenly
this old lady comes by and tells them
that new immigrant workers have just
moved onto the island to work and will
live at the same apartment as everyone
else while they're here as the new
residents move in this lady bumps into
some of the new arrivals they introduce
themselves as Yuri and Yuri's mom she
welcomes them but warns these two about
her creepy son who likes to draw scary
pictures and leave them all over town
she says that her creepy son is harmless
but these two have no idea that this kid
will set off a series of horrifying
events later that night Kimi is playing
on the roof of her her apartment when
she notices something sinister in the
forest looking right at her but suddenly
Yuri pops by and introduces herself and
the two agree to become friends wanting
to show off Kimmy decides to show Yuri
the scary basement that she discovered
earlier and the two head down there
begin exploring but that's when they
notice a secret door open up Curious the
two head inside and suddenly noticed
horrifying drawings stuck all over the
walls Yuri then recognizes the drawings
and thinks that it may belong to the
creepy kid that she was warned about
from earlier and the two quickly head
back home the next day some villagers
begin to notice piles of dead fish near
the apartment and they begin to freak
out and try to hide it from old lady
landlord meanwhile Kimmy leaves her
apartment and she heads down this
hallway but notices that one of her
neighbor's doors is half open Curious
she goes inside to check it out and she
suddenly sees the horrifying corpse of a
creepy kid covered in Moss okay this is
crazy and gross because this kid Not
only was Cree creepy as hell but was
essentially a shut-in and never left his
room Kimmy and Yuri discovering his
horrifying drawings all over those walls
means that he really wasn't that much of
a shut-in however him almost never
leaving his room made him either the
hardest or easiest Target in the world
depending on if the mother was home when
his murder happened but what doesn't
make sense is why the killer didn't try
to kill creepy kid down in the creepy
basement where he left his drawings
because the killer would have had to
keep tabs on creepy kid before killing
him and would have likely already known
about his hangout spot down in the
basement as this would have likely made
a much better spot to kill him and would
have been way less risky the killer
committing these murders in the
apartment itself means that this
murderer has a serious set of balls and
is super confident about their ability
to get away safe and sound and likely
means that the Killer is someone that
can travel unseen through this building
and also has a reason to travel to
various floors with a seemingly
non-threatening look about them in order
to be able to blend in the hard part is
is that everyone is staying in the same
building here including those immigrant
workers which means everybody is already
in close proximity with one another and
they pass by each other on a repeated
basis this means that the Killer is not
likely who we think it is and these
people can afford to get distracted by
pointing fingers towards the easiest
Target the body covered in Moss however
is another mystery and something that
doesn't make sense because moss in
general is a plant that likes to grow on
hard porous surfaces like stone or wood
where it finds enough moisture and
mineral nutrients the fact is a dead
human body is not a good environment for
Moss to grow due to all the organic
compounds of water in the tissue that
encourages bacterial growth this makes
the human body basically toxic for
plants and the fact that the corpse was
entirely covered in Moss means that
there is no normal way that Moss could
have formed their natural as in
generally it takes at least 6 weeks up
to two years for Moss to begin thriving
on a Surface this means that it could
not have formed overnight to that extent
because what Kimi is seeing is just not
humanly possible I would also begin
looking into the Moss and what it could
represent as in various cultures have
different concepts about plants and they
can represent different symbols
understanding the reasoning behind why
the Moss is there in the first place
could take us one step closer to
figuring out what kind of statement the
murder is trying to make and the better
we can understand him the better we'll
be able to figure out what all of this
means and what the killer plans to do
next news about the dead kid's corpse
begins to spread all over and all the
neighbors begin to start to freak out
and word gets out that the dead kids
family has suddenly disappeared taka
then meets with his friends and finds
out that the locals on the island have
started to suspect that one of the
immigrant workers may have kidnapped the
dead boy's parents and everyone starts
to become a little bit paranoid later
Kimmy heads over to play with Yuri as
Yuri's mom offers to help her make the
iced dessert for the apartment party
later but out of certain ingredients
Kimmy talks to Taka and he asks their
new neighbors if they have any
ingredients that they could borrow
agreeing to help the Immigrant workers
offered to make the syrup for the rest
of the apartment party not realizing
that this event will turn into a
horrifying day excited for the party
Kimmy began singing folklore songs about
the island but she messes up the lyrics
so bad and Yuri begins to get really
annoyed Tonka then clarifies what the
ancient song is really about and
mentions that thousands of years ago an
ancient power was delivered to this
island at a sacred site somewhere on the
mount and this power was delivered by an
ancient sea god named kuzululu this God
and his people eventually settled on the
island and began serving the locals and
the king of the land taka suspects that
according to this ancient song him and
Kimmy's Island ancestors were once part
of an ancient civilization from under
the sea taka Chuckles at the Island
story but he will soon regret ever
talking to these girls he continues
blathering on but Yuri gets really bored
and runs off and Kimi and taka suddenly
bump into one of the islands above his
immigrants Boulder shoulder guy and they
see him freak out over the this Moss
plat and he says that where he comes
from he's never seen any plant as
beautiful as this one while at the same
time really creepy and adorable suddenly
taka realizes that the rock that he
found in the basement May belong to the
ancient kusalulu people and he decides
to go do some more research and Boulder
shoulder guy notices The Rock in taka's
hands later that night the neighbors
notice even more dead fish all around
the building and they begin to think
that something terrifying is happening
scared Yuri's mother offers to let the
locals use her security cameras that she
set up near her apartment and everybody
tries to figure out who's leaving behind
all of these dead fish later taka and
his friends show up at Boulder shoulder
guy's house and tell him that they've
caught him on camera and blame him for
all the fishiness that's been going on
but that's when they find out something
shocking Boulder shoulder guy confesses
about what he did last night but he's
not the one that left them he was the
one that was cleaning them up he saw a
pile of animal corpses right outside of
Kimmy's apartment revealing to Taka that
he was just cleaning up the mess and
told them where to go to prove his story
right finding out that he's telling the
truth the gang realizes that someone or
something else is causing all of this
Boulder shoulder guide then agrees to
stay in for the night and the group
decides about what to do next this dude
wearing red pants then agrees to stay
awake and provide the night watch red
pants guy sets out to start the night
shift leaving taka and his friends he
heads up these apartments stairs but he
suddenly hears a strange noise following
the sound he reaches this floor just as
he gets brutally murdered the next day
the ice dessert party is about to begin
and Kimmy and Yuri and taka stop by
Boulder shoulder guy's house to pick up
the syrup for the party Kimmy then
quickly has a taste of the syrup and the
three head downstairs moments later
everyone begins celebrating and Kimmy
has another scoop of the iced dessert
but that's when she notices that it now
suddenly tastes disgusting just then
taka and his friends find another pile
of dead fishes realizing that red pants
guy from last night is nowhere to be
found scared for their friend this guy
rushes off to go find red pants guy
breaking into his apartment he discovers
that his friend's corpse is also covered
in red moss and now Boulder shoulder guy
and everyone else at the Party begins to
realize that something else is off about
the ice dessert and taka suddenly
discovers an animal head floating inside
of the syrup oh that's so gross okay
this is terrifyingly disgusting because
right now discovering this animal head
almost guarantees that whoever put this
in this pot is also responsible for the
strange occurrences happening on the
island recently I'm starting to get a
little freaked out because now this is
too much of a coincidence and the animal
head being discovered in a meal itself
means that this attack was personal and
is meant to serve as a statement since
it was never meant to harm anyone but
merely act to serve a point that whoever
is doing this wants to ruin all
relations on this island and wants the
absolute worst things for everyone here
at this point blaming the immigrants
would be the easy move and the most
obvious one which makes it unlikely that
they would be the ones for responsible
especially since them further escalating
tensions with the locals in the first
place would only make their life on this
island a living hell and even more
miserable why would they do that which
means that just like whoever killed
creepy kid this person was able to
confidently fly undetected among the
apartment residents and would be someone
that we least suspect as I said before
however the one thing that doesn't make
sense right now is the fact that Kimmy
didn't notice the strange taste before
when she tried the dish back at Boulder
shoulder guys apartment she only noticed
the difference in taste after they
brought it to the party you know what
this means right folks this means that
someone must have placed the animal head
inside of the dish during the time
between when the dish was moved from
Boulder shoulder guys apartment to the
party and while we don't see who had
early access to the dish it likely would
have been one of the three who carried
it to the party at one point or it could
have been someone who would have been in
charge of coordinating the ice dessert
party in the first place since they
likely would have overseen and come into
contact with the dish before before
anyone else normally would have we gotta
put on our Sherlock and start narrowing
down the list of people who had the
earliest access to the dish as this will
likely lead us to the person causing all
of these Horrors the whole village is
horrified and think that the immigrants
are responsible for this sick joke while
the immigrants think that taka is the
one to blame since he had been studying
that rock with the strange markings on
it and think that the animal sacrifices
are because of his devil worship taka
denies the accusation and says that he
found that rock in the underground
basement but nobody listens not
realizing that a horrifying God is
already hiding among them the days go by
and the police give up looking for the
missing people thinking they just moved
away but taka begins to suspect that the
piles of dead animals people Vanishing
and the Moss are all connected and he
thinks that the person who sabotaged the
ice dessert party did it because of
Kimmy and he fears that all of this has
to do with the ancient song about the
God kuzu Lulu later Yuri shows up to
Kimmy's apartment and the two decide to
get to the bottom Above This Island
mystery themselves that is a really bad
idea girls what are you doing anyways
the two begin to investigate the locals
and the immigrant workers but soon find
out that no one knows anything arriving
back at home later they reach Kimmy's
apartment door and they see terrifying
blood and feathers right in front of it
and they suddenly hear a horrifying
scream come from nearby they Rush
downstairs and find the locals beating
down Boulder shoulder guy Kimmy demands
that they stop this but they mentioned
that they caught him carrying another
dead animal with him just them Bolder
shoulder guy's brother arrives and calms
the situation down the group thinks they
know who's to blame but they don't
realize that this is all just a
terrifying distraction early the next
morning takak had sleep and decides to
go for a walk just as he runs into
Boulder shoulder guy's brother who tells
them that because of everything that's
happened he's decided to leave the
island before things get worse but
mentions that his brother has decided to
stay and he bids taka farewell but
sudden taka notices a rainbow in the sky
and runs up to this hill to see the full
picture but that's when he realizes
something horror he sees the rainbow
point to his apartment and he realizes
that the power that kuzululu delivered
to the sacred site was not on a mountain
but at the location of his apartment
discovering a moss Stonehill right under
the rainbow and he thinks that this area
is somehow a gateway to another realm he
heads down to the secret door and
discovers that this is the spot that
creepy kid used to hang out in and he
continues his investigation later that
morning Kimmy and Yuri decide to spend
the whole day with Boulder shoulder guy
because they feel bad as he had just
gotten beaten to a pulp the other day
the three then decide to stop by taka's
apartment but that's when they realize
that he's not home and they realize that
something is wrong Kimmy then thinks
that taka could be in the underground
storeroom and everyone rushes there but
that's when they realize that creepy
kid's drawings have now been torn to
shreds older shoulder guide then
discovers the same markings on the wall
as he saw on taka's rock and figures out
that the Rock left behind that room is
in fact a key and the two small girls
managed to squeeze through this small
door and discover a room filled with
ancient texts and drawings Yuri then
reads the drawings and finds out more
information about the kuzululu myth
figuring out that the island song that
Kimmy was butchering so bad that song is
actually true but discovers that after
the fish people's God died they came to
the island Shore in search of trying to
find a way to resurrect their dead
leader and try to sacrifice themselves
to the God of this island mountain in
the hopes that the God would bring
kusululu back however the humans already
living on the island try to attack the
mountain God and the fish people gave
their lives trying to defend her Kimmy
is terrified and interrupts Yuri telling
her to shut that Fajr before she craps
her pants okay this theory about the
island myth is horrifying and makes me
think that what's going on here has more
to do with the past than everyone
initially thought from the beginning we
saw dead piles of fish in animals
showing up for seemingly no reason
around the island and more specifically
Kimmy's place and then on top of that we
find out from Kimmy that the eyelid
itself even had their own mythical song
from the past that mentions that the sea
and his people had something to do with
the creation of this island and now
we've only found real life evidence to
suggest that whatever is going on on
this island has something to do with the
island and myth itself now look at this
the ancient cave picture itself is one
of three main types of rock art which
includes petroglyphics which is carved
rock art in paleontology one of the ways
to tell if rock art is genuine would be
by analyzing The Rock patina acquired
over centuries of Aging along with
radiocarbon dating that is used to
determine how old something is by
checking on the decay of its radioactive
carbon Isotopes also known as carbon 14.
carbon 14 is the longest lived
radioactive isotope of carbon who's
Decay allows the accurate dating of
archaeological artifacts but given the
fact that Kimmy and Yuri are not rock
experts and can barely reach the top of
a cookie jar above the fridge this makes
me think that these two wouldn't have
the slightest clue when it comes to
being able to tell whether the cave
paintings are real or not which means
that we have to go off the fact that
whatever these drawings are telling us
is the downright truth and knowing doing
this this means that Kimmy and her Squad
finally have a vague picture as to what
is really going on here and means that
we can use this to predict what Horrors
might come next especially if we
consider that the dead piles of animals
and fish when looked through a religious
lens could mean that these acts are
offerings to a higher power in exchange
for something and this means that what's
going on could be happening because of a
religious Cult of some sort that has to
do with kuza Lulu and his followers and
if we consider what has happened so far
this means that it's more than probably
likely that all of these acts the murder
the animal sacrifices and strange events
were committed by more than one person
and likely by a group of people
coordinating with each other and if this
is true then this means that this island
has more than one killer snooping around
that means that everyone here is in more
danger than they initially thought
seeing Kimmy scared Yuri tries to
comfort Kimmy and says that she'll
protect her no matter what Kimmy has a
vision of soldiers entering this cave
killing a bunch of people in order to
get to her and Yuri said suddenly
sacrifices herself to protect her Kimmy
is shocked at her vision and tries to
keep it a secret as the two head back
outside to meet with Boulder shoulder
guy telling him that taka is nowhere to
be found forcing everyone to head back
home and call it a day but Kimmy Kimmy
then heads back to her apartment and
goes back to talk to her fetus mother
and she terrifyingly reverses time and
space there and then later that night
Kimmy then heads to taka's friend's
apartment and hands him taka's notebook
with no explanation as to how she found
it and she suspiciously runs off
stopping at Boulder shoulder guys placed
next she hands him taka's rock and a
letter and tells him to only read it if
he's ever in trouble the old guy starts
reading taka's notebook and discovers
that his earlier suspicions about the
kuzululu God and the fish people were
wrong discovering that the kusolulu
people held rituals to sacrifice land
and sea animals to bring their dead God
back to life with the help of the
Island's Sky God a horrifying Cosmic
being that could manipulate time in
space but when this guy attempts failed
the fish people began to sacrifice other
humans until a war erupted and the whole
island got destroyed taka's notes also
revealed that he thinks that the sky god
of the past is still on this island
hiding among the residents in human form
and this is why the descendants of
kuzululu's followers came back to this
island the piles of dead animal
offerings means that they've already
begun to try and bring back their
horrifying God one more time suddenly
though this old guy realizes that one of
the sky God's Powers according to the
myth is moss a symbol of peace and
Eternity and this means that the sky God
this whole time is the reason behind the
mosque being found at the site of the
murdered victims in order to help the
victims live on in the afterlife this
guy then realizes that one person sweet
enough to do this and the person who
found the first victim is Kimmy the girl
worshiped by the whole island and whose
family has never ever been seen before
she is the secret Island God the old
dude is horrified at the news and goes
to find Kimmy before the kuzululu people
try to get to her he reads her apartment
and bangs on her door but that's when he
suddenly gets stabbed by none other than
Yuri's dad who is also wearing glasses
he's a Kusa Lulu follower elsewhere
folder shoulder guy finally reads
Kimmy's note and he reads her apology
letter to him he then goes outside and
sees Moss all over the floor and
discovers that the old landlord lady
next door has just been brutally
murdered by Yuri's mother she tries to
stab him but he uses his well-developed
oh my gosh that is so funny Tom she
tries to stab him but he uses his
well-developed glutes to Chuck Norris
roundhouse kicker knocking her out and
he goes to try and find Kimmy also
meanwhile Kimmy tries to find Bolder
shoulder guy when he runs into Yuri's
dead AKA glasses guy and he suddenly
charges at her like a psycho and tries
to sacrifice her but Yuri saves her and
tells Kimmy to run Boulder shoulder guy
then finally shows up and sees Yuri
fighting with her dad but something is
horrifyingly wrong as the two suddenly
stop fighting and smile at Boulder
shoulder guy he's horrified as year then
says that she's going to go off to kill
sweet Kimmy and tells her daddy to go
deal with Boulder shoulder guy glasses
guy then reveals to him that it was his
family that brought in the foreigners
knowing it would cause a disruption to
the Prejudice locals and that this would
distract them from what his family were
really trying to do and he charges at
Boulder shoulder guy preparing to kill
him right here and now uh okay this is
kinda nuts because by now it's obvious
that Yuri and her family are the ones
behind everything and this means that
these people are kuzululu followers
which means that they're crazy as hell
and once again we should have guessed
that the guy with glasses turned out to
have the biggest amount of glasses guy
energy we have ever seen now despite
Boulder shoulder guys roided up size
Advantage compared to glasses guy I mean
he is huge compared to glasses guy but
he still needs to be cautious because
one he's unarmed and too much likely
slower than glass's guy but at this
point that is about all that Boulder
shoulder guy has his size so he has to
use it in law enforcement there is this
rule the 21-foot rule which is is a
guiding principle that states that an
average person can cover 21 feet in
roughly 1.5 seconds with the intent for
police officers being that they have
this much time before they can draw upon
their firearm in an active situation and
Boulder shoulder guy is likely within
that 21-foot rule in relation to where
glass's guy is standing which means that
he does have time to be able to get to
the man before glasses guy can use his
crowbar and then basically he man the
crap out of glasses guy enough to either
remove the Crowbar from his hands or at
the very least temporarily disorient him
all that being said though glasses guy
is a follower of a cult aimed at
creating a new world order which means
that is likely to assume that this guy
is a total nut job and insane enough to
the point that he's more than likely
willing to die for his cause and he's
already murdered people already which
means that Boulder shoulder guy has to
be willing to do the same otherwise
Boulder shoulder guy could make a
mistake and die right here and now
glasses guy attacks Boulder shoulder guy
and he crumbles to the floor Yuri's
mother suddenly shows up and he tells
her to finish the job but she too scared
and glasses guy tells her that he'll
kill her if she doesn't do it and she
listens like the good girl that she is
and takes a shot just as Bolder shoulder
guy reveals the rock that he was holding
on to that had the ancient markings
magically stunning both of them just as
he sees Yuri running after Kimmy he
tries to warn Kimmy that Yuri is
actually evil but Yuri blocks this
Corridor the two girls disappear into
this cave Kimi then notices Yuri
creepily smiling just as she sees her
whip out of Blade and Kimmy realizes
that she's about to be brutally murdered
she quickly crawls for her life and Yuri
follows her out of this hole into a room
she thinks that she has Kimi dead to
right but that's when Kimmy reveals her
mother this little fetus Yuri gets
confused just as Kimmy crushes the fetus
with her foot revealing a pile of moss
underneath Kimi then tells her that
she's done with this place and suddenly
body parts of Yuri's mother and her
father begin appearing from thin air
right in front of her and Kimmy reveals
the horrifying truth about her and this
island Kimmy is the God of this island
the one Yuri and her family of kuzululu
followers were trying to contact she
tells Yuri that she throws this island
in time and that the residents of
housing complex sea have been living in
the year 2000 for over 20 years tired of
the human race Kimmy has been watching
over Humanity for over 20 000 years
hoping that one day Humanity would be
worthy of saving and that's the reason
she froze this island in time she tried
to preserve this island Purity but
thanks to the locals mistreatment of the
foreign workers and Yuri's murderous
family Kimmy has realized that Humanity
isn't worth saving Yuri is shocked as
Kimi tells her that it was her powers
that covered all the corpses and moths
in an attempt to calm the locals into
not freaking out all she ever wanted was
for Humanity to try and live together in
peace Yuri then freaks out and bows down
to this God begging for forgiveness
saying she'll do anything kill anything
for her but Kimmy is ruthless and
brutally murders and declares Humanity
as the most selfish race in the universe
right as she begins destroying the
entire area meanwhile Boulder shoulder
guy reaches the surface just as he sees
a beam of light consumed the entire
Island he prepares himself for death and
is ready for the horse but realizes that
he's been spared and The Rock and his
hand disappears the only one left alive
on this island hey if you like this
video don't forget to like comment
subscribe and check out the how to be
playlist down below